quando la bambina pensavo di avere a me
ha due strade
o avete fatto la ragazza ho già toppato
quando hai fatto la scrittrice aver
fatto la ragazza cin cin l'ananas
decisamente non so se ve le ricordate ma
secondo me a vedervi qualcuno si erano
quelle ragazze molto belle
molto rosa perché poco vestite che
facevano dei balletti complessissimi ea
un certo punto si aprivano reggiseno e
mostravano il loro sorriso migliore
e alle ragazze tutti i frutti di colpo
grosso
ma ce ne fa una bambina di colpo grosso
niente io sapevo solo che erano
bellissime e che volevo essere l'ananas
la mia casa è una casa senza filtri e
senza tante altre cose
ed ero io a un po riflettuto è quello
che dovrebbe fare raccontarvi una storia
di miseria affettive un po struggente ma
non è quello che voglio fare dal mio
cuore raccontarvi una cosa il mio padre
raccontarvi che io sono nata chiedo già
orfana ed è la prima volta che di quella
palla o fan a voce alta in vita mia mio
padre è mancato tre settimane prima che
venisse al mondo non ci siamo incrociati
e per tre settimane
io probabilmente non ne sarà ricordata
di lui ma probabilmente lui per un
attimo si di me e quindi ad un certo
punto della vita arriva quel momento che
arrivato per tutti alle elementari in
cui bisogna scrivere il tema il mio papà
e io era una bambina autonoma non è
educata al pianto senza riferimenti
senza braccia adesso cui andare ho fatto
il mio tema inventandomi un sacco di
cose bellissime
tentando proprio
ea un certo punto secondo me la maestra
lina
si è resa conto
di essersi dimenticata e che il papa non
ce l'avevo e fosse un po piene spiace
perché aveva i sensi di colpa
ha cominciato mettendo bravissima in
tutti i temi tra l'altro vorrei farvi
vedere che scrivevo che una bambina alta
i piedi sono rimasta nella più alta
della classe
e me lo scrivevo con questa grafia
bellissima o forse abbiamo capito che
volevo fare la scrittrice
era molto bella ma questi è molto bella
aveva questi ricci
il rossetto proprio rosso e teneva sulla
carta da questo secchiello di uno prende
come a dire a tutti che lei era una
maestra un po la mode
e sempre le stesse maestre elementari
erano quelle che tutto il santo
pomeriggio mi facevano ripetere rana
rana rana senza alcun fondamento di
logopedia perché secondo lei dovevo
quale giornata che io non volevo
proteggere che è la stessa identica che
oggi mi fa inciampare e mi farà
inciampare
e sempre piccolissima più piccola era
nata
hanno sbagliato a scrivere il mio nome
meglio hanno sbagliato trascrive lo
dall'ospedale in quel breve tratto tra
l'ospedale e l'anagrafe e valina casco
ma un nome bellissimo che è preso da un
film degli anni 70 con alain delon è
diventato vannina
che permetterà di bile che poi va dal
nome bellissimo da donna tutta d'un
pezzo da una chiesa quasi ma all avana
piccola non si può sentire
e da quel momento è stato studiato
eternamente vanina viviana vania vanessa
marina non so per quale assonanza
piazzino vanina vanini perché mi chiamo
vanina viviani come domanda di stendhal
ma questo mi piaceva molto di più e
quindi da lì in poi ho ricevuto solo
messaggi mail dall 81 ad oggi molte
qualsiasi cosa con il nome storpiato è
una cosa che mi infastidisce
moltissimo un piccolo errore perché
qualcuno non ha pensato nell 81 che
fosse importante correggere il mio nome
quando sono nata non era importante in
quel momento lì
ma vi dicevo che questa non è la storia
che io vi voglio raccontare
anche se sarebbe molto interessante
perché il mio albero genealogico
praticamente si sviluppa in orizzontale
come per i forrester di beautiful
amavano tutti molto e non in verticale
un sacco di impeachment
non me lo voglio raccontare il mondo il
pudore o per vergogna
ma perché se c'è una cosa che capisci
subito quando viene al mondo
è che quel buio quelle miseri affettive
non sono nella vita di tutti
la vita di tutti voi e che quindi per me
non aveva senso mettermi lì e fare la
conta
del presunto essere indietro ma che
arrivavo nella vita c'è il tabellone con
le penalità già in partenza quello che
vi voglio raccontare e come la bellezza
le cose belle mi abbiano sollevata non
salvata che è un'espressione che non mi
piace sollevata trasportata la bellezza
per me è stata una zattera per andare
incontro a delle altre cose
ma un certo punto sono
cresciutella
e ho pensato ai cantanti e davanti a me
due strade
avrei fatto la scrittrice
oppure sarei diventata la direttrice di
playboy italia
perché c'era sempre se donnine con tutto
questa rosa fuori bellissimi mi ricordo
laura antonelli
però su playboy scrivevano anche le più
grandi firme del giornalismo della
letteratura e questo spessissimo noi ce
lo dimentichiamo
e a questo punto sarebbe più che
legittimo pensare ma insomma colpo
grosso le ragazze cin cin lei money
questo da grande voleva fa la zona
e invece no perché aveva questa
attitudine tutta personale di vogliono
rendere poetica qualsiasi cosa della mia
vita persino la mia data di nascita
io sono nata il 21 aprile del 1981 mi
sento una reggina al 21 aprile è nata
una regina minore
bellissima tra l'altro ma il 21 aprile è
data anche silvana mangano e lato iggy
pop di 21 aprile in effetti è nata anche
jessica rizzo
che non so se qualcuno di voi conosce ma
la breve ricerca in internet vi
racconterà che non è esattamente nota
per le sue doti canore o fogli da dow
jones
a un certo punto ho cominciato io mi
chiedo una ragazza strana che poi strana
cosa vuol dire non si sa
papà mi ha anche un po piaciuto in
effetti secondo me
ad un certo punto è stato anche un
povero perché quando tutte le bambine
giocavano alla parrucchiera a fare le
pizze ag rotonda fa il veterinario io
che avevo un ego già smisurato io
giocavo a via delle apparizioni
io giocavo a vedere la madonna e siccome
avevo le apparizioni dovevo avere un
testimone di queste apparizioni che poi
purtroppo è la mia sorella minore
martina quindi noi abitavamo al settimo
piano di questo condominio quindi vicini
al cielo
potevo solo aveva un'apparizione quindi
camminavano mano nella mano a un certo
punto io
immobilizzava davanti al cielo mi
inginocchiava avevo questa apparizione
mi ricordo anche che cantavo fortuna non
mi ricordo il testo ma con la madonna
cantando e mia sorella poverino a quel
punto lei doveva scappare fuori e
avvisare qualcuno che stava avendo con
l'apparizione qualcuno che di solito non
c'era
via sorda invece giocava
a fare televendite dei tappeti non so se
vi ricordate
trent'anni fa andavano molto di moda
soprattutto sulle reti private e c'è uno
quegli uomini e quelle donne che per
un'ora massaggiavano un tappeto con
l'intento di vender velo le giocava
quello quindi tanto in bolla non doveva
essere almeno lei
insomma in questo navigato in queste
stranezze quello che io ho capito
perfettamente
che la bellezza è un posto
fisico o anche immaginario immaginario
nel fisico e viceversa è un luogo
la bellezza e quel luogo in cui tutti
noi stiamo bene
la bellezza in tutto perché questo tutto
è soggettivo
e affidarsi a questo senso del bello per
me è stato il mio modo di essere libera
allieve nella mia vita di non vedere
tutte quelle brutture che mi portavo
dietro che poi ti porti dietro un po
tutta la vita
la bellezza è un incanto
incantare vuol dire cantare la formula
magica la formula magica per cosa per
essere altrove in quell'altro veli dove
poi tutti voi siete e quindi mi sentivo
libera di essere fedele a me stesso che
non vuol dire essere me stessa è essere
se stesse a volte un po della pendevo le
accettati
essere fedeli a se stessi vuol dire
essere la massima espressione di se
stessi e quindi poi te ne frega anche un
po che ti dicano che che sei strana per
me è la bellezza sono mille sfumature di
un rosato rosso e addosso di teatro cioè
noi la bellezza sono le prime i primi
secondi di una canzone di tempo di gino
paoli li avete tutti quei primi secondi
di una canzone che magari le parole non
sono neanche cominciata sentite l'inizio
e siete già di là in quel posto lì di
bellezza
per me è la bellezza non ha fatto di
rita levi chiediti vara feriti era il
nobel con un abito di capucci coi
capelli raccolti col suo cameo
talentuosa ma fiera e raffinatissima
quel momento lì mi porta altrove quella
foto di mi porta da un'altra parte
per me la bellezza è comprare
centinaia di foto di patenti di libretti
di matrimonio di pagelle di persone che
non conosco perché io amo moltissimo la
mia vita ma anche tantissimo quella
degli altri
e mi perdo ora guardarle passera sono
tutti ha fatto originali e sfuma e
bellissime finita in qualche mercatino
per me è la bellezza compra delle
lettere d'amore
manoscritte con un i messaggini lì
adesso è domandarmi se hanno risposto se
poi si sono amati se si sono conosciuti
se questa lettera arrivata poi al
destinatario oppure no
la bellezza per mera mandare delle
cartoline con il segno del rossetto io
spendo un sacco di soldi in vacanza per
mandare delle cartoline però mi piace
perché le persone sono contente perché
così il postino può fare un pò
l'impiccio né invece di portato tempo le
buste inutili e se voi mettete in un bar
a scrive delle cartoline che magari
anche abbracciarle vi assicuro che si
fermano a guardarvi
per me è la bellezza è l'omino delle
poste di catania che quando vado per
spedirle mi chiede se lascio un bacio
anche lui la mia lunga un foglio io
lascio al bacio e poi mi accorgo che la
denuncia di smarrimento diliberto
postale e anche questo secondo me è
bellissimo
la bellezza per me una casa governata
dalla carta
c'è una cosa che io detesto quando le
persone vengono a casa mia e quando mi
chiedono ma tu questi libri dei letti
tutti
ma tu hai fatti tuoi
io ho capito perché mi dà fastidio e mi
dà fastidio perché noi ci sentiamo
sempre di doversi giustificare
di fronte a queste domande invece noi
dobbiamo raccontare perché le persone
vogliono sapere
a ma io adesso non dico più quando me lo
chiedono se gli eletti si leggerà se li
sto leggendo
adesso da quanto panta bello costruire
una biblioteca e dico che a casa mia
anche se lo aspetti non sarà anche
peggio perché io voglio che la casa mia
casa diventi come la libreria acqua alta
a venezia
peggio di quella che è ora
per me è la bellezza e ricavarmi uno
spazio in casa
inaccessibile e anche mio marito c'entra
e dicendo formali tra l'altro mi sono
anche appena rovinata la piazza
ed è una stanza piena di abiti vintage
di cose inutili di cose rotte perché
quell'abito la dà mandato qualcuno
quell'abito magari l'ha indossata una
donna felice e anche può a volte mi
chiedo ma qualcosa te ne fai
io mi chiedo lì dentro se voglio penso
di essere dalida per un momento
la bellezza per me è chiamare un
ristorante e prenotando con un altro
nome vi dicevo che a me il mio nome
piace tantissimo ma nina non sbagliate
però se ci pensate il nome sono portiamo
dietro tutta la vita e non è quello che
ci siamo scelti noi la prima cosa che
fosse dovremmo sceglierci quindi fatte
senza snobismi questo esercizio pensata
quel nome che vi fareste dati da soli
panni fermate me lo dite chi mi vorrà
chiamare al ma con alma mahler
suona benissimo così come invece mi
chiamo marina quando per note ristoranti
lì ben noto come alma così io so che
potrò andare
dire buonasera prenotato un tavolo nome
alma e quindi saranno per un minuto
l'aver pronunciato me lo sono anche
tutti i miei amici e questa per me è la
mia bellezza
il senso di essere altrove di essere
libera di essere la massima espressione
di me quindi chiamate stasera e dite che
siete george clooney in giro
e se siete strani non importa poi sono
cresciuto ho compiuto 40 anni e spero di
aver messo abbastanza illuminante oggi
da dimostrarne qualcuno di meno ea quel
punto ho avuto sempre due strade davanti
a me
prova dei fatti la scrittrice
oppure avrei passato verso del tempo
pensare a quello che avrei voluto fare
nelle altre vite
perché questo non mi basta e non perché
non mi piaccia
è che io voglio di più
e poi faccio lavoro bellissimo adesso
lavoro in un'azienda che si occupa di
bellezza che vende prodotti di bellezza
potevo finire solo lì
ecco io nelle prossime vite
vorrei fare tre cose vuole fare il
soprano col talento ho dovuto vorrei
essere come sono adesso qua ma adesso
come maria callas con un bel abito di
velluto la collana di perle a vedere che
mi lanciate le rose
aspettare le lettere i fiori dietro
degli spasimanti
oppure vorrei fare il trapezista che ha
detto da me che ho paura delle strade
senza bordo che non mi asciugo i capelli
se non ho le scarpe sono tate una fifona
potrebbe essere qua
su un'altalena un acrobata incapace ma
con un pullman
meraviglioso o poi di più vorrei fare il
negoziatore con quello di business non
cui mi parla di soldi
avete presente quello che è lì vicino a
uno che al dodicesimo piano che si sta
per buttar giù e tu lo devi convincere
che no che non si fa
e qui vorrei persuadere le persone a
vivere
questo mi piacerebbe tantissimo come
lavoro
insomma in tutte queste tappe a un certo
punto mi è successo molto spesso molto
molto quotidianamente di sentirmi dire
che doveva essere un filino meno figlio
non meno sopra le righe
non so come ma da noi in lombardia si
usa dire adesso anche meno
e pedalino esempio messo la mia
collezione di abiti animali
minimalismo puro anche meno ma meno di
cosa meno perché io penso che invece
dobbiamo traboccare che traboccare
essere fedeli a se stessi essere la
massima espressione di se stessi non
vuol dire essere ingordi
non vuol dire essere abili vuol dire
essere pieni di desideri
quindi quello che vi voglio dire che è
la bellezza un posto
abitate lo e poi volete mettere la
bellezza pensate al gesto tribale quasi
primitiva di un applauso a scena aperta
[Musica]
[Applauso]